Let's discuss the relationship between LSQ entries, ROB
entries, and reservation stations. When we issue a
load or a store instruction, we need a
ROB entry. Every instruction needs a ROB entry. So,
when we issue a non load/store instruction, we also get a ROB entry, and we get
for a non load/store instruction a reservation station
of the right type. For loads and stores that
we get a LSQ entry. These act as a reservation
stations for loads and stores. So note that we can
not issue a load or a store unless we have
both a ROB entry available and an LSQ entry available.
Just like we couldn't issue a non-load/store instruction if we
didn't have both a ROB entry available and a reservation
station of the right type available. When we execute a
load/store instruction, there are actually two parts to that execution.
First, we need to compute the address. Second, we need to
produce the value for a load. That means we first compute
the address, then we get the value from memory. For a
store, actually this can happen in any order. We are computing the
address, while we are also trying to obtain the value of
the register that we need to store to memory. We write the
result only for loads. For a store, there is no write
of the result. The store simply keeps the value and the address
in the load/store queue for other loads to get
it, and for the store to finally send it
to memory on commit. But the load, as soon
as it gets that result, will broadcast that result to
dependent instructions. So that pretty much all the reservation
stations that are waiting for that register value can
now proceed. So note that our load/store unit, although
it doesn't have reservation stations, it has the load/store queue.
So when it finally figures out the value for the load,
it needs to broadcast it to subsequent instructions so that it
can be woken up and use that value. They will get
that value from the load/store queue. To commit a load, we move
the ROB head, basically, we free the ROB entry. And we
also move the LSQ head; that is, we free the LSQ
entry. And we need to do the same thing for stores.
For stores, in addition to this, we have to send the write
to memory. Pretty much, we've been holding onto the
address and the value until we commit the stores.
So at the time we, when we commit it,
we need to finally send that value to memory.